the gyro can experience different things
like that I think i think one bullying
moment that I even kind of forgot about
till going through this with dr. Raymond
was I was in the locker room and this
little guy named Raiden that I've been
hanging out with a lot he was just beat
up in the bathroom I saw that video the
video that was online is a horrible
video of these kids beating him up but
then I saw him with you yeah yeah so
that's been fun what are you doing with
them just man it's it's great working up
the spirits yeah you just wanted to to
rally around him it's awesome surround
them with love inside work into passion
we're in the same town no [ __ ] in the
same town Oklahoma State Oh Oh actually
Jamie is it okay to play one of those
videos I saved
it's called Raiden videos and it's the
first one but just sort of people that
haven't seen it a you and Dakota talked
about this
enuine Laird about the diffusion of
responsibility so it's yes and people
can just stand around and watch right
well that's what happens right and in
the in the urinal actually not this
video but the next one this one's a fun
supportive one and then this one right
here is just him at the urinal going to
the bathroom kids you know I don't want
to watch this just real quick after that
there's so that's him at the urinal
there's 8 to 10 kids in the bathroom
they actually think up to 12 4 or 5 or
just filming it and he's got special
needs who's born with autism deaf in his
right ear so he's got a hearing aid he's
diabetic
he's got diabetes and his family and
he's been relentlessly bullied since he
was 9 years old
this is him that there's so the bathroom
was on Thursday this is on Friday after
school three kids jumping them hitting
them from all sides for no reason for no
reason he's a big teddy bear
and he just his mom said since her
picking them up at school in
kindergarten first grade second grade
kids would just walk up and hit him in
the stomach or punch him in the arm
okay what's enough yeah we don't have to
keep playing it so but it's really cool
that you reached out to him yeah well
they they I guess knew about fight for
the Forgotten and we're in the same town
and so a dad reached out to Jim Stewart
and you've met Jim he's our director and
Jim hit me up right away and said hey is
this a kid that we could we could rally
around though you could you know we want
to do all this we have a curriculum for
a bully prevention and I think character
development is bully prevention so yeah
good character you're not gonna bully
well that's one of the things that I've
always said about martial arts yeah
believe it or not like learning how to
fight is one of the best ways to keep
people from being [ __ ]
absolutely which is so counterintuitive
but it really is because a lot of people
being bullies it comes from a lack of
confidence right and confident people
are generally pretty kind yeah confident
accomplished people and you know
yourself so you don't have these need
this need to improve you don't have that
insecurity yes right and the other
beautiful thing about gyms particularly
jiu-jitsu I think is that everybody kind
of boosts everybody up it's a real
family sort of camaraderie feeling a
real those environments almost every gym
I've ever been to every jujitsu gym it's
good they have this family environment
to it and it just makes you feel like
you belong somewhere and you get used to
being kind to people nice to be yeah
even even if someone catches you with a
technique they'll show you yeah they'll
show you this is you know you left your
arm here when you were transitioning and
if you do that it gets stuck and this is
why I can catch you yeah humble hearts
yeah so with with jiu-jitsu or with
martial arts if you hurt your training
partner you lose right the person that's
helping you get better yes and so as you
help them get better they make you
better and it's just give and take we're
actually the more you give the more you
get in return because you're making them
a better training partner a better
person and I think martial arts takes it
to another level I've done numerous
sports my parents I grew up with um
being the professional or official
photographers of like the Dallas Cowboys
and the Texas Rangers and the Dallas
Mavericks and so I grew up around
professional athletes but what's so
different I think about martial artists
and why people love MMA one because the
sports so pure and it's like a chess
match and it's an incredible sport but
the athletes they truly are more
approachable and I think that they're
more giving and compassionate and more
community minded and driven you know
that other athletes aren't but just a
martial artist are so more yes because
they've had it drilled into them from
having mentors and other black belts
yeah that are on this lifelong journey
of even service to others that's part of
the black belt journey and self-respect
and discipline and
[Applause]